the overwatch beta has been wrapped for
about a week now but blizzards action
shooter is still on our minds the
developer has just released a ton of
statistics gathered from the beta and a
lot of you will be happy to know that
Bastion was killed 326 million times but
that's not the only stat Blizzard
tracked so who were the most popular
characters from the beta for offense it
was soldier 76 for defense it was
Widowmaker for tank it was Reinhardt and
for support it was mercy players
switched characters 271 million times
during all the matches averaging about 8
swaps per game and when those games
ended over 87 million loot boxes were
earned that's a lot of numbers but it
all just boils down to a ton of you guys
playing the beta over watches beta may
have wrapped but the full game hits pc
xbox one and ps4 on May twenty-fourth
thanks to global servers booting up
simultaneously some of you will actually
be able to grab the game and start
playing on the 23rd you can head over to
gamespot for everything you need to know
about the game before it launches and
for all things overwatch blizzard and
shooters you're already in the right
place
you